today's number is 82 000 which is a
weird number to kind of arbitrary
sounding number to talk about
because this is what i want to do
imagine this sequence
i'm going to start this sequence with a
2
a
3 four
the next number eighty-two thousand
what's the next number
i'm not going to talk to you with this
one i'm not gonna make you do the riddle
for this one because we don't know what
the next number is so this sequence is
about using different bases
normally we use base 10 base 10 means
well if i took a number like
231
then what that means is we are doing two
lots of 100 which is actually 10 squared
we then add on three lots of ten itself
and then we add on one lot in that case
of ten to the zero so one lot of one ten
to the zero is one and so that's how
regular numbers work it's powers of ten
that we're adding together but there's
nothing special about the number ten so
we can do this with any number we can
choose any base and in general if we had
a base
let's call it
base b what that means is we're using
the digits 0 1 2 3 up to
b minus 1
and then we
are looking at powers of b
so
that would start with b to the zero
which is one and then it'd be b itself
then it's b squared and b cubed and b to
the four shall we have a little bit of
practice shall we do that in a different
base yeah let's do it in base five it's
231 in base five it's written as one
four one one it's still the same number
it's still 231 it still has the same
size so i'll do base six doesn't really
make that point have a look so in base
six
it's written as one o two three so we
can write numbers in different bases
all right let's do this for eighty two
thousand let's see what we get in
different bases let's start by doing it
in base two right that's my simple one
you can do all right in base two it is
and i have to look this up 101.
zero zero zero
another zero zero zero zero one zero
one zero zero and a couple more zeros on
the end of that uh what does this mean
uh this means it's
2 to the 16
plus
2 to the 14
plus
2 to their
six
plus two to the fourth so that's that's
what it looks like in base two in base
three it looks like this one one zero
one one one one one zero oh one
right let's try it in base four it looks
like this one one zero zero zero one one
zero zero
i'm gonna do one more base five let's
look at that what are you expecting to
happen
now one
zero one one one zero zero zero
what's happening is in eighty two
thousand in every base well base two
base three base four base five it's
written as ones and zeros it's always
ones and zeros so a number doesn't have
to be written as ones and zeros in base
two
numbers are always written in ones and
zeros but in base three you know we have
no digit twos here in base four we have
no digit threes here for eighty two
thousand it's always written in ones and
zeros and it does appear
to be the only number
that has this property that can be
written in ones and zeros in base two
base three base four and base five as
well let's take a look at the sequence
why is this a sequence then
because if you were only talking about
base two then the smallest number you
could write using ones and zeros without
being one itself which is too easy is
the number two in base 2 it's 1 0 and
that's the number two the smallest
number you can write using base two and
base three
in ones and zeros only is the number
three if i'm allowed to use base two
base three and base 4
using ones and zeros only the smallest
number i can do that is the number four
if i allow to do it in base 2 base 3
base 4 and base 5
the smallest number that you can do that
with ones and zeroes only is eighty two
thousand
so it's pottering along nicely and then
suddenly from eighty two thousand
and this might be the only number
that you can write so what's the next
number
the next number is a number or the
smallest number that we could write
using base 2 3
4 5 and base 6.
now unfortunately 82 000 fails to do
that on base 6. let's look at that in
base 6
82 000
is written as this
1 4 three are already i'm disappointed
one three four
four
so ah
it's already failing there now if there
is a next number there
it would have to be written in ones and
zeros in base six
but it has to be written in ones and
zeros in base five and four and three
and two we think
eighty-two thousand is the only number
that can be written like this
up to base five so there can't be one
that satisfies this for base six as well
because it has to satisfy all the others
it's an open problem it's still an open
problem and we have checked numbers
up to 2 000 digits long so we have
looked for this
is it the only number
and then if there is another number
is that number a candidate for the next
number in this sequence because i take
that a step further and look at base 6
then
today's episode of numberphile has been
brought to you by a book not just any
book it's this one how not to be wrong
by jordan ellenberg this is a bestseller
it's really popular lots of people i
speak to have been talking about it in
fact the quote here on the front says a
delight full of simple yet deep insights
about many areas of modern life and that
quote is from alex bellos who is in
loads of number five videos so what more
recommendation do you want jordan may be
known to a lot of you through a column
he writes for slate which is very good
and the book is like that but even
better i mean obviously it's very clever
mathematically but also really funny and
witty he's a really he's a really smart
guy and makes you laugh while you're
reading it which i really like he's also
a genius at chapter names
check out some of these these are
chapters in the book less like sweden
everyone is obese how much is that in
dead americans the baltimore stockbroker
and the bible code dead fish don't read
minds i could have told you that
what to expect when you're expecting to
win the lottery miss more planes there
is no such thing as public opinion i
love the titles he uses i think i should
employ him to write the titles for
number five videos if you like books
about mathematics you'll love this and
if you don't read books about
mathematics this is a good place to
start this is one of the best ones out
there how not to be wrong the hidden
maths of everyday life is the subtitle
although i have seen it with other
subtitles elsewhere you'll find it
everywhere you normally get books from
and i'll put a link in the video
description if you want to go straight
to it and add it to your collection i'm
reading it at the moment and when i
finish it will be going on a little
shelf i have over there full of all my
favorite math books and thank you to a
book and what an appropriate book for
supporting numberphile